hello there and thanks for taking the
time to view our webinar on precision
medicine
my name's dr. Ben Chaffee from kaijin
and I'm joined here today by my
colleague dr. Dave hope from insight
genetics and we'd like to discuss with
you the newly approved courage and
thorough screen fgfr rgq rt-pcr kit and
the rapid adoption of this test at
insight through the kaijin day1
readiness program
we'll provide an introduction to the
test and an overview of bladder cancer
which is the disease indication and run
through the performance of the test and
the overall day1 readiness concept after
this they're going to discuss his
personal experience of bringing the test
online at insight before we have a
general wrap-up and conclusion
to introduce myself my name is Ben
Chaffee I'm a member of the oncology
Diagnostics global product management
team here at Cajun with overall
responsibility for commercialization of
new companion diagnostic tests in
oncology including the thorough
screening FGFR rt-pcr kit with partner
labs around the world
I'm molecular biologist and immunologist
by training with over a decade of
experience now in the IBD industry
covering a wide range of roles including
assay development product manufacture
and product management based in
Manchester in the UK this is the kaijin
global center of excellence for
companion diagnostic development and the
site upon which the product was
originally developed
hi everyone my name is David health I'm
currently the chief operating officer at
Nashville based company called inside
genetics five over 15 years of
experience and development design
throughout my tenure I published
extensively and presented extensively on
development validation performance both
qPCR and next generation sequencing
clinical assays and also certified as a
licensed laboratory supervisor so I have
extensive experience in the CLIA and cap
compliance and feel welcome everybody
so a general introduction to bladder
cancer and more specifically your
ethereal cancer
represents slightly more four and a half
percent of all new cancer cases
diagnosed each year in the USA and of
these cancers your ethereal cancer is
the most commonly diagnosed form it's a
disease primarily of older people the
median age at diagnosis being 72
and for patients diagnosed with a
localized case of the disease by via
survival is pretty good around eighty
two and a half percent
however for patients with advanced
unresectable or metastatic cases of
bladder cancer the 5-year survival is
very poor less than 5%
development of the disease is more
frequently occurring in men rather than
than women and it's associated with
various lifestyle and environmental
factors such as cigarette smoking
working in the organic chemicals
industry are working with rubber
compounds
Vladek ounces are divided into
stages according to their degree in
tissue invasion and morphology at the
time of diagnosis
starting out with a non-invasive tumor
growing on the surface of the bladder
into the bladder lumen progressing
through to a superficially invasive
tumor which is invading through the euro
thulium but has not yet reached the
bladder muscle layers
progressing to a deeply invasive tumor
which is reaching into the muscle of the
bladder but not penetrated beyond then
tumors which penetrate all the way
through the bladder muscle and reaching
the layer of fat on the outside of the
organ and finally deeply invasive tumor
spreading throughout the bladder the
pelvic region and with distant
metastasis
it's necessary to carry out a detailed
investigation of each patient's case to
what to optimize the treatment that they
receive and the outcomes
as a visual illustration of these
different stages of the disease we have
official tumors which appear a little
bit like a deep-sea coral growing from
the urethane eel surface into the lumen
of the bladder
grass into a more invasive kind of tumor
spreading through the wall of the
bladder and out into the pelvic region
options are available for different
stages of bladder cancer the superficial
disease surgical management is usually
performed frequently using a trans
urethral resection of the tumor with in
Treviso call either immunotherapy with
BCG the source or with chemotherapy
agents instilled into the bladder
if the disease progresses further other
lines of treatment can be brought into
play
these can include either a partial or
complete cystectomy and systemic
chemotherapy and in more advanced cases
of the disease
external beam radiotherapy and then
finally immune blockade therapy for
patients with the most advanced disease
and for patients with advanced and
metastatic disease there's now a new
treatment option a targeted therapy very
recently licensed called bal versa or
Oda fitter nib
this is a new small molecule drug which
has been commercialized by yunsun
biotech the pharmaceutical arm of
Johnson & Johnson it is an orally
administered pan fgfr4 fibroblast growth
factor receptor tyrosine kinase
inhibitor and was awarded breakthrough
therapy designation by the FDA in March
2018 for the treatment of advanced or
metastatic year aetherial cancer on the
grounds of safety and efficacy data
drawn from phase 2 study of this
compound plc 2001
or versa is an effective new treatment
option for patients for whom a few other
options were remaining
Pulver sir is only active in cases of
your ethereal cancer which harbour
specific alterations in the fgfr gene
these are activating alterations which
are known to be present in around 20% of
advanced bladder cancer cases these can
be point mutations or gene fusions both
these forms of FGF are alteration are
activating and lock the FGFR molecule
into a constitutively active form which
then drives cellular growth and
differentiation and spread
therefore to use al versa
it's necessary to identify patients
whose disease harbors these activating
mutations and CDX test is required
Cajuns have worked with the ansan to
develop this companion diagnostic test
which is the thorough screen FGFR RG
qrt-pcr kit
this is the first fda-approved companion
diagnostic test for identification of
actionable fgfr gene point mutations and
fusion events
to guide valve versa therapy when
treating cases of advanced your ethereal
cancer it's a real-time reverse
transcription PCR test for the
qualitative detection of two point
mutations in exon seven two point
mutations in exon ten and two fusions of
the fibroblast growth factor receptor 3
gene in RNA samples derived from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded euro
theol tumor tissue specimens and this
test is indicated for use as an aid in
identifying patients with cases of euro
Theal cancer that harbor these
alterations and are therefore eligible
for treatment the kit is currently only
available in the USA
it contains all of the reagents which
are required to perform a qualitative
real-time reverse transcription PCR test
on RNA extracted from FFPE you ethereal
cancer tumor material the RNA is
prepared from the tumor specimen using
the R and E Z DFP FFPE kit from kaijin
this test is the only fda-approved
companion diagnostic on the market at
present to identify patients for therapy
using FGFR inhibitor drugs
it detects the clinically actionable
alterations in the fgfr3 gene which are
predictive of response to Barr versa
and enables highly sensitive and
specific identification of point
mutations and fusions
that's required to run the test is
included in the pack it's optimized for
analysis using the kaijin rotor chinkyu
MDX thermal cycler and runs with the
rotor gene as a manager software version
2.1 which automatically determines run
validity and FGFR alteration status
formed using a simple and
straightforward workflow
nicoleff FPU athili or cancer tissue is
sectioned and macro dissected if
necessary to achieve a 80% tumor area in
the specimen with an input area of
between 100 and 500 square millimeters
of tumor tissue RNA is purified and then
this RNA is used as the basis of a
reverse transcription reaction to
generate cDNA using reverse
transcriptase supplied in the FGFR
rt-pcr kit this cDNA is then the
template material for the real-time PCR
reactions which determine the presence
of actionable alterations
this workflow is well aligned with the
workflow of other existing stereo screen
tests and is a natural addition to this
well-established portfolio
during the
trial of bal versa a clinical trial
assay was used to identify patients for
recruitment
in order to establish clinical validity
a bridging study was carried out
to demonstrate equivalent performance
between the thorough screen kit and the
clinical trial assay which was an LD t
now you can see here from this table of
results that the thorough screen kit had
a good positive percentage agreement of
87% with the clinical trial FA a very
good negative than agreement with the
overall percent agreement of ninety
three point eight percent
accordance between the Thera screen kit
and a reference method of droplet
digital reverse transcription PCR showed
an extremely high level of concordance
between this reference method and the
ferrous green kit and was used to
determine the biological truth in some
discordant samples identified when
testing with the clinical trial assay
and the Thera screen kit which concluded
that the thorough screen kit actually
has a higher specificity than the
clinical trial assay
demonstrates that the Thera screen kit
provides accurate results consistent
with the test used in the clinical trial
averted fitness
tubes supplied in the kit which are
sufficient for testing of up to 24
samples
reagents used to perform reverse
transcription step
control and positive controlled element
mix
the real-time PCR reaction mixes which
come blended with attack polymerase
already and then some water for use as a
no template control and also for a
dilution of samples
commercialization of this test has been
carried out using the day one readiness
approach by Karen working with some of
our highly qualified partner
laboratories in the USA to accelerate
the timeline over which access to this
testing can be made available to
patients who so desperately need it to
identify whether they're able to be
prescribed this innovative new therapy
what is the overall day1 readiness
concept
under normal circumstances setting up a
new test can take labs months after it
becomes legally available but by
preparing with carefully selected
partners before approval and launch
cousins able to make this testing
available in close coordination with
launch of the drug dramatically
accelerating the rate at which patients
can be identified and their treatment
commenced
the overall result of this is
significant enhancement in the care
delivered to patients through an
elimination of delay
how's this process achieved
step is to carefully select partner
organizations on the basis of their
capabilities and to establish and then
maintain an ongoing dialogue through
which we can share information and work
very closely together to eliminate
uncertainties in the program and solve
problems as they occur
we can utilize all of the available
regulatory mechanisms to enable staff
training on new workflows and
verification of the tests prior to
launch and then upon approval and launch
synchronize activities between Kuragin
and partner organizations in this launch
period to ensure that everybody is fully
aware of everything that's taking place
dream line the delivery of the kit
material to the labs make sure that
healthcare providers are well aware of
the laboratories who are offering
tests and accelerate delivery of that
testing service
to a factor here is that success is
dependent upon their being an effective
team very much a team game and to try
and operate independently it's
guaranteed to fail
so at this point I'd like to
over to Dave and he can then give you an
insight into his personal experience of
being part of the day one program for
launch of the fgfr test Thank You van
and welcome everyone thank you for
attending so has been indicated we are a
day one ready lab for hydrogen inside
genetics is kind of is separating the
two different entities or D based entity
that does a lot early phase development
where the assay has developed and in
position well for inside molecular lab
which is a wholly owned subsidiary of
inside genetics it's a CLIA and cap
certified laboratory these assays that
are developed within inside genetics can
then be well positioned for a CLIA
offering we've had a long-standing
relationship with kaijin to early phase
development programs and currently or
one of the u.s. labs performing a lot of
the reproducibility and repeat repute
ability for these athletes such as the
fgfr therasp um say this is beneficial
to the lab because it gives the lab
experience and training with the assay
during the RN our studies the data from
these reproducibility studies has been
fed into the FDA documentation paddock
packet that's submitted by Ketchum once
we have experience with the assay and
before it becomes a live PMA we can live
through the CLIA lab perform the
accuracy precision analytical
sensitivity reportable range and
reference studies that need to be in
place for the CLIA validation and on on
day one rate
scribing a little bit of our experience
with the verification of the fair screen
we use bottle cancer enthalpy slides
where macro dissected to attain a
minimum of 80% tumor to marry between a
100 millimeter square and 500 millimeter
squared the Kaizen kids that were used
or the RNA easy DSD FFP kids the fair
screen at GFR rgq rt-pcr kit and interim
instruments used for the roto gene mdx
instruments the roto gene as a manager
and a gamma in the x plug-in version
over here on the right is the handbook
and one of the good experiences with
doing this early early clear validation
was that we can provide input into the
handbook or critical input of what was
not clear when we were doing the studies
and these three chains and the handbook
itself can also provide background
information for CLIA validation to
expedite its with the verification
report
but talk a little bit about the
verification over you the FGFR kid
validation was conducted using kids
supplied under iuo labeling according to
the FDA drug CDX co-development traffic
guidelines the validation was conducted
in six phases the phases are labeled
here below sample processing analytical
accuracy precision sensitivity
reportable range and reference range the
FGF our kit workflow is a universal
unidirectional workflow from sessioning
pcr setup RNA isolation and post pcr
because of a requirement to carry out a
two-step rt-pcr process this in
synthesize of cDNA we pipette the 55 P
DNA into for PCR to - for further
processing and a96 well plate then
pipette from the 96 well plate into the
final PCR tubes
this ensures tight unidirectional
workflow yeah
pays one sample processing again there's
the requirement for a 100 millimeter
square to 500 millimeter square tissue
at least these slides have to be
evaluated by a pathologist before sent
to the testing laboratory the tomb area
has to be marked on a slide by
pathologists because the assay is micro
that the samples are micro affected the
samples extracted partner are extracted
using an RNA easy FFP kit and the
minimum RNA concentration is sixteen
point six seven nanograms per microliter
to meet the 250 nanogram input in the 15
microliters RNA a concentration is
measured or measured using the nanodrop
instrument results from phase one in our
hands that RNA concentration range was
from around 100 6.5 month nanograms per
microliter to 315 nanograms per
microliter we have it there was an
average of 184 nanograms across all the
samples all samples met Mpho
requirements verifying sample processing
Phase two the analytical accuracy and
I'd like to everybody know that all of
these phases were done under the
standards from the clinical and
laboratory standards Institute ran
illegal accuracy there was a requirement
of 95 percent or greater accuracy across
20 specimens that were tested results
from this study that we observed that
the FGFR kid called samples a hundred
percent of the time of the lower
confidence boundary of 86 percent the
results meant objective of the 95%
accuracy assessing
phase three precision the FGFR kid is
incorporated a qualitative test and thus
the measured closeness of qualitative
agreement with within run and within lab
there was again a requirement 95 percent
or greater precision across 80 replicas
and in the precision at Levesque FS
using the confusion table results from
the study we observed the MTF archaic
called samples a hundred percent of the
time with a lower confidence boundary of
96 percent and then therefore the
results met the objective with 95
percent
concerning analytical sensitivity we
assess free samples at 2x LOD again
there was a requirement of 95 percent
greater sensitivity and it was assessed
using a confusion table results from the
study we learned that the fgfr kit
called samples are 100% of the time with
a low confidence boundary of 90%
the reportable range is a functional
range of an assay on which an aniline
can be measured with a set input of 250
nanograms for RNA for the fgfr kid
therefore we assess each sample or
passage of internal control for which
fish in the Theriot was input again
there was required at 95% or greater
successful IC amplification results we
observed at the IC amplified 100 percent
of the time the lower contest boundary
at 98% to met the objective
last phase the reference range is
typically intended to assess expected
values to occur 95 percent of healthy
population if Jeff our kid requires a
patient be diagnosed by with by a cancer
by a physician and so we assess to
confirm that fgfr operation negative our
cancer sample were measured as well type
requirement again with 95 percent of
greater specificity results we observed
that a hundred percent we deserved a
hundred percent specificity with the
lower confidence boundary with a set
person which again met our reference
range assessment
in summary each of the study validations
and metamour exceeded that 95% threshold
established by the clinical laboratory
standards Institute required for each
part of the study with varying lower
confidence bounds the study of the assay
is very robust reproducible accurate and
precise
our experience and our data from our
CLIA validation I'll turn it over to Ben
to finalize the presentation
thanks a lot
so in summary
the Thera screen FGFR rt-pcr kit is the
first fda-approved companion diagnostic
tests to identify actionable alterations
in fgfr genes and thereby identify
patients who are potentially eligible
for therapy with the new and FGFR
bothing kinase inhibitor bal versa this
is a significant development in the
treatment of bladder cancer because
historically treatment options for
patients with advanced or metastatic
bladder cancer have been extremely
limited and this compound has been
granted breakthrough therapy designation
by the FDA on the strength of its life
prolonging effects in patients whose
disease harbors these specific
alterations
the testing has been made rapidly
available through the cash in day one
readiness program through which we've
worked with carefully selected lab
partners the deliver testing in
coordination with drug launch and
facilitate access to this gold standard
companion diagnostic which has clear
linkage to the clinical trial results
and if I could ask you perhaps to add a
couple of points Dave
Thank You Ven in our hands we have it's
now live in our lab we are getting
multiple requests for the tests we have
now set up our own lavatory Z code for
the test and we are currently in the
process of ordering kits and offering it
live within our laboratory
and so that's the status with us if we
hadn't done it this way it would have
taken probably another couple months
just to validate just to clear validate
the lab and we would not be ready for
for testing and at this time so this
this think this process the day one
rating this was very beneficial to
inside genetics thanks thanks a lot
but there are any questions from the
audience please feel free to direct them
to either myself or to Dave
there are some questions already which
we can try and address now
question-is FGFR alterations can be
detected by several multi-gene NGS
panels
why should testing be carried out using
the thorough screen PCR test rather than
an NGS test
I'll address some of the the relevant
detail this question to begin with
significant advantage of the Thera
screen kit is that by using RNA as the
input sample material we were able to
detect both point mutations and fusion
events in one PCR reaction whereas if
you were to use an NGS solution for this
it's almost certain that to identify
this range of alteration type two rounds
of library prep would have to be carried
out one on DNA to identify the point
mutations and one on RNA to identify the
fusion events this obviously has
significant consequences in terms of the
throughput time taken to generate a
result from the receipt sample material
and overall testing cost and we know
from our conversations with clinical
colleagues that patients who are being
considered for treatment will but with
valve versa are often profoundly unwell
and time really is of the essence when
returning these test results to them so
making the difference between test
results which can be generated over the
course of a few days in comparison to a
test result which can be generated over
the course of a few weeks is really
significant
you
there are also some issues with the CLIA
lab itself offering NGS testing but most
CLIA labs don't have the bioinformatics
expertise that they need to interpret
NGS results whereas the Kaizen kit has
basically a yes or no result there's
more suited to the CLIA lab there's also
an issue of cost
NGS essays typically cost more than qPCR
acids additionally more even though the
QC s are as saying as PMA approved and
has a higher price tag it's still not as
high as NGS there's also the issue of
instrumentation costly instrumentation
for NGS and issues sometimes with free
produce ability with some of the NGS
data so from a CLIA standpoint qPCR a sa
is much more favorable
so I think we have a couple more
questions other questions come up are
there any issues with the day one ready
process we did not see virtually we saw
virtually no issues except for the fact
that we did identify an issue with the Z
code application process so kaien cannot
apply for their Z code until the PMA was
actually approved this is a new
requirement and so getting our Z code
for our clay lab we had to wait until
kaijin receipt it's because before we
can get our Z code now this does not
stop testing reimbursement that are
attempting to get reimbursement that can
hold up reimbursement so it needs to be
really seamless and coordinated so that
you're not waiting around for for Z
codes to get to get approved
and then another question has
reimbursement for the test bennett
established we have not fully
established reimbursement within our
laboratory although other laboratories
are also running the test and may have
we do have work closely with kaijin to
put together a reimbursement strategy
and a reimbursement packet if the test
does get rejected on the first
submission so this day one readiness
kind of organization where we're
constantly talking with kaijin is
constantly talking with jensen allows
this strategy to be a little bit more
clear and and clairvoyant to the payers
and we expect that we will not have a
whole lot of difficulty in getting
reimbursed for the assay
thanks Dave and also the mission for a
PLA code is underway to cover this test
specifically
but then that's it for all of the
which are on the screen for us at the
moment if anybody has any further
questions please don't hesitate to get
in touch we're both available via email
and if you send your questions in a will
endeavor to respond to you as quickly as
possible thank you very much
thank you